the particular role of Larry Talbot was
definitely one of his favorites and as
many of you may know he played all of
the horror characters he plays son of
Dracula he played Frankenstein's monster
and he played the mummy in several
different roles as well but it was the
Wolfman that I think you know he bond
with and it meant so much to his career
it was his favorite character and role I
wanted to read a couple of quotes that
what it meant to my grandfather because
that's a question I'm often asked you
know what does that role really mean to
him I mean where was it in his career
and how did he feel about it and I mean
I could tell you all night long you know
what it means to me as this grandson of
watching him and meeting so many
wonderful people you know it's allowed
me that opportunity which you know I
really enjoyed but I think probably best
I'll put it in his words what it really
meant to him and these were some quotes
from a book he was working on called a
century of Cheney's but this is a little
bit of what he wrote about the Wolfman
and really would have meant to him of
all the characters I've been I liked
Lawrence Talbot the Wolfman the best
because he belonged only to me the
others such as Dracula Frankenstein's
monster the mummy and I I only followed
I didn't create I seem to identify with
the Wolfman he never wanted to hurt
anyone during his period of sanity in
between full moons he begged to be
confined chained even killed to avoid
the horrible consequences of his curse
he was a classic product of
misunderstanding and I knew him well you
know so many people get identified for
their particular roles but you know Jack
Pierce doing the makeup the guy was just
amazing I mean simply amazing you know
he was around the time that my
great-grandfather was doing makeup in
films at Universal so you know they had
an association but certainly I think he
carried that legacy on
lon chaney like nobody else could have
and created his own niche in the
business and it's kind of hard to
capture some of the magic of these early
Universal horror films but I think in
some cases it's been touched on and I
think with the creativity of not only my
grandfather and what he brought to the
role but Jack Pierce and the director
and all the other people in cast and
crew and everybody that makes a film
really come together it's pretty amazing
but I think it's the influence that
they've touched on with so many
different people because I see that when
I go to shows occasionally and people
call me or introducing Hema that kind of
sounds like you know is it Dick Cheney a
launch an Iran you know but when I say
lon Cheney and they're not always sure
the name but then if I say phantom of
the opera' hunchback or a Wolfman and I
mean it's just like that they're so
iconic but the influence they they cast
on so many I think continues obviously
with the second film you're going to see
American Werewolf in London of John is
the director David and Rick Baker's
amazing work you know these guys have
just carried that torch and flame and
done amazing things with it and you're
looking at you know certainly Rick one
of the greatest makeup artists there has
been and I say his work I've had a
wonderful opportunity to meet him and
you know the influence that you see on
so many wonderful artists Mike Hill and
and others is just pretty amazing and
I'm so proud to be a Chaney and what my
family has done to contribute to the
film industry thank you very much